l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vigenti ed oggi siamo
tornati su sly forio slide come cazzo si
chiama ancora non l'ho capito come parto
sempre con delle skin che fanno
veramente pietà fatemelo usare una
decente anche figata hanno aggiunto tipo
un record in alto a sinistra oggi il
verme più lungo è stato slider io con
una lunghezza di 609 mila ma come cazzo
ha fatto ma se io per arrivare a 10mila
do minacciarle mamme dichiarato sto
gioco ragazzo ha fatto con l'affare 600
che era thai ecco infatti che in realtà
melo pupa sono io sono in coppa dio ci
sono macedone uccidono a carissimo a
prodotti con su questo porca vacca o
come velo pupi ai vai vai ben oa ma come
posso essere così in [ __ ] accade
unico senti e ditemi voi se io devo
perdere con gente così ma vi rendete
conto la situazione grave il primo è
adolf ma non eri morto al sema quando
quanti punti quanti punti di crema
raggiunto un ragazzi mi fate uscire da
qualche sono incastrati stimo potete
morire
ciao lei la crisi di morire mi spiace
mai mai mai bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye veloce da che credono tutti
sono di tutti chi è morto qua anche
questo che fa no cazzo suo corpo quello
malizioso nella morto pure adolf eccolo
con il primo a bere lezzi riscrivere la
storia ammazzo io ad alfa franco
montegrosso dallo stesso muore lo so me
lo sento
e infatti lo sapevo maledetta la
germania
no
[Musica]
ma da franco è morto anche lui quanta
gente ma se sbatti sulla noè che brutta
frase mio papà mi ha sempre detto nella
vita devi avercelo più grosso grazie
papà che mi hai dato sempre questi
consigli e adesso sono quello che ce
l'ha più grosso e rata a dolcè un po più
grosso però a un magnum e lo magno
malagnino sento l'orgoglio tutto tipo lo
yogurt paganucci dolci dolci non ci
lucida quanto lo zucca ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi oddio peso che sei punti sono
andiamo 11 milan 11 mila fa il dj 6 sto
tentando subito in classifica 12.000
punti
newsweek grosso questo secondo è seconda
ma che cazzo vuoi la mia vita il secondo
in classifica ha tentato di uccidermi ma
non ce l'ha fatta 13.000 punti dai dai
che sesto è buono se mi vuole il secondo
in classifica di vento più grosso che
prima che memore questo è morto è morto
è morto meno grasso
no a nuovi ammazzo le famiglie e dai
quattro in classifica ma [ __ ]
ma come of art a morire quarti in
classifica di mortacci lehto mark pam
povero pia male il perchè dovete
rompermi i tre quarti sono i miei punti
cosa volete da me ex su cup
ci manca solo che ti lamenti mo.ma di
mbor lamentati sul serio ciamei [ __ ]
i miei punti non mi dovete rompere le
palle
che iddio sante magno frate marais come
l'ho fatto ma tac deficiente rava
rompermi le palle la prossima volta
beh a voler riuscire tue è morto è morto
con la grossa meno pupi lo sapevo lo
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
vai vai vai vai vai vai veloce
velocissimo ma torna vantino presi
grandissimo sono duemila sono partito
subito potente ciò che il karma mi avrà
per questa cosa che sto facendo però mi
dispiace di libererò zio tranquillo ti
libererò mi sto perdendo tutti il karma
mi ha punito per aver incarcerato eccolo
napoli che cazzo eccidio oddio vai vai
vai vai 7400 un ragazzo ogni modo
abbastanza messo bene diecimila solo no
no è morto che quello vai vai vai veloce
ma dai stronzo di morire ma perché mi
fotte rito un'ultima cosa vuoi la vita
mia dodicimila rega sesto sono i nuovo
sesto sono a 12.000 punti di nuovo
incredibile ora non facciamo i pirla che
quando arrivo sempre a questi punti poi
muoio con un deficiente sempre non c'è
una volta che muoio del centro è sempre
comunque gli one movie il piano piano si
però dovete farvi cattiva bravissimo
[Musica]
lanciato il mouse e invece ero vivo sono
un [ __ ] che io lancio il mouse che a
volte sul terzo sono terzo nel server
dai cazzo dovete crepare se io adesso
resisto resisto e aspetto che crepino i
primi per me un record adesso io chiamo
mia mamma dopo questo gameplay e lo dico
perché sarà contenta non è che riesco
tipo ad accerchiarlo mentre lui a cerchi
altra gente si procede che cazzo fate
tutti vicino a lui ma porca [ __ ] ma
fatemi una vita
come cazzo sono morto in cui unito ma
che morte di merda sono andata a
schiantarsi contro uno per a fermo era
guarda i primi classifica quanto sono
19mila ci arrivavo tutta la vita perché
ho dovuto fare il [ __ ] perché
all'inizio in teoria potete questo è un
consiglio che vi dò io in teoria non è
possibile
mi si è schiantato un gigante in faccia
e culo assurdo mi si sono mangiati tutti
i punti è però vabbè mentre vi stava
descrivendo la tattica era proprio
questo che vi stavo per dire ma come fa
a essere così efficiente ma se per ti
metti che ben mi metto davanti ma gira e
poi parlo io che mi chiami sono
schiantato un rincoglionito prima ma
perché sono io che ti ho preso perché
sono morto io ho preso io per loro
muoiono ora che secondo e tu pensi poter
battere me è molto molto molto molto pam
ma come mi ha schivato maledetto madonna
come l'ho ucciso come sono forte quanto
sono forte gli ho fatto il culo a ma mi
incontro che ti vuoi mettere adesso lo
uccisero preso per i mente tutti i punti
che aveva e non sono diventato grosso
come lui quindi questa è la prova che si
ammazzi qualcuno di grande non diventi
grande quanto lui però che aumenta un
botto questo sicuro grande madonna
quanti punti ci sono in questo punto ma
vabbè quanta roba non mai visto così
tanti punti sluyter io da modo ci gioco
mai madonna vanta roba ora qua
incredibile
mica quanta roba ragazzi fantastico trek
dac tutto io x tutto io 12mila sono
settimo vai forza prima una 28 dai dai
dai che ce la faccio dai adesso il mio
obiettivo è quello di uscire da qua
perché sono tutti qua che mi rompono il
pene che mi se riesco a magari levarmi
dal casa perché sono al centro proprio
dalla mappa ecco che non oso pensare
quanta gente mi sta seguendo in questo
momento mi sta seguendo proprio il verme
aspettando io crepi de morisse il cugino
tanto non muoia
deficiente che palle fatti una vita è
batista bene guarda di morire un
grandissimo e vabbè non morirò me lo
sento me lo sento perché qualcuno tenta
di prendere i punti al posto mio
mi sono salvato no no figlio di [ __ ]
quanto non muoio a 15.700 non come prima
ho fatto per gli eventi niente da fare
meglio di così
ma vera che a suo dire che posso
concludere qui il video visto che
alimentando tragico sto gioco non
riuscite croce la farà arrivare primo io
me lo sento ce la posso fare ma edizione
primi temi sempre 100 comma 6 se vi è
piaciuto al documento è un mi piace
anche la pagina facebook come minata da
tiziana si eserciti ska 10v dialogo
subito